now you're not going to have a country
that can make these kind of rules work
if you haven't got men that have learned
to tell human rights from a punch in the
nose
the most famous filibuster in history
was fictional
when mr smith went to washington either
i'm dead right or i'm crazy
you wouldn't care to put that to a vote
would you senator but over the years
there have been plenty of real
and often ridiculous ones cato the
younger
gets the earliest historical credit when
he tried to thwart julius caesar's plans
in ancient rome
the word filibuster sprang from the
dutch word fributter
meaning pirate or plunderer it really
took off
in the u.s senate huey long reciting
salad dressing in oyster recipes in an
attempt to block a confirmation
bob laflette nearly inciting a brawl by
threatening to chuck a brass spittoon
and strom thurman using a sauna to
dehydrate so he wouldn't have to use the
bathroom
allowing him to speak for more than 24
hours straight
which remains the record in the 1950s
and 60s in particular
thurman and a group of senators used the
filibuster frequently
to block civil rights reform it was
southern democrats
who were filibustering against their own
party and it was the democrats and
liberal republicans who were voting to
try to
to stop those filibusters the historian
emeritus of the senate don richie joined
us this week
with talk of eliminating the filibuster
back in the news post-election
why do so many people support it if it
causes so much obstruction
it's frustrated people for
hundreds of years is there anything in
the constitution about filibusters
there is a very small phrase in the
constitution that has a lot of weight in
this
and that is that each house of congress
can write its own rules
there are a lot of misconceptions about
the filibuster what's the biggest
i guess the biggest is that people think
you have to stand up and hold the floor
by yourself for hours and and
just talk there are in fact silent ways
to stall
today if someone does speak up it's
usually because they want media
attention
like ted cruz reading green eggs and ham
i do not like them sam i am i do not
like
green eggs and ham or rand paul
objecting to u.s domestic drone policy
which had previously brought a challenge
in federal court
fueled by milk and candy bars
to the legality of the authorization to
target milwaukee and yemen
every time you have a majority that
really wants to get something done
they object to the minority filibuster
today the filibuster does remain
an annoyance for any new leadership and
maybe
always will i've discovered that there
are some limits to filibustering and
i'm going to have to go take care of one
of those in a few minutes here
i think the talk about filibuster reform
will probably
uh be more intense at the very beginning
of this congress and won't be
necessarily on the agenda after a while
and then we'll just do it again in
tour exactly right
so one senator at one point tried to
build a contraption to help with
potential delays or breaks it broke
we won't talk more about that since it's
breakfast time but a couple other
interesting notes about filibusters
i'm sorry the rules yeah okay the rules
have changed over the years so that you
can't filibuster judges and so
the new administration will get judges
through cabinet members through
legislation might be a slightly
different story and the rules also
changed in the 70s to allow those silent
filibusters
too so you don't have to stand up and
you said that was such a straight face
jeff
i can't believe it